so much against trans rights it's
against a version of trans rights that
is directly opposed to women's rights
the the you know I I'm friend one of the
ironies of this whole thing is that I'm
friends with more trans people than the
people calling me transphobic and they
are
um uh you know destroyed at what's been
happening supposedly in their name you
know uh Debbie Hayden is a good example
Miranda Yardley is another one
um they they both find this
um as insane as as as as I do but their
voices are ignored because this is an
ideological battle it's not an ethical
battle this is Battle of ideas and if
you have the wrong idea at the time at
this particular time
I don't know I mean I guess you can call
it Council culture although that
sometimes seems like uh not quite the
right phrase but but everyone is
frightened everyone uh would rather go
away which is why they offered me so
much money to go away from Ted